snow creeping into the area last night
check out this video sent to us by some
of our viewers this one some decent
snowfall up at the mount charleston
hotel there this happening around 10 p.m
last night and we had some good snow up
on charleston
[Music]
this second video coming from the
mountains edge area some of those flakes
finding their way to the ground this
video was taken about 10 this morning
sent to me by a viewer from the
southwest part of the valley you can
kind of hear a little bit of of the
actual sound of it hitting the ground so
it's more of a rain snow mix because if
it's actually just flurries it's going
to come down quietly sure when you're
hearing that it's going to mix in itself
you know it's rare what is it when lost
fagans get to use the snow emoji yes it
doesn't happen often we don't do that
much we use the sun emoji a lot no but
the snow emoji that goes viral yeah
right especially busted out once in a
while live look outside guy and i want
to thank everybody guys we had so much
email sent to us so much on social media
of all of you showing us your video
sharing your video and your pictures
we'd love that stuff so keep it coming
doesn't even have to be a wacky weather
day just send us your great sunset shots
we'll we'll show it on tv and on social
live look outside right now a whole lot
quieter than earlier today where we did
say we would get some snowflakes and
even some showers around the region
that's what we saw this morning and even
around midday 73 degrees on sunday okay
that was our high it was mild for you it
was warm for you but then look at the
high today only 48 huge temperature
difference from sunday we need to reach
50 today and that was our official high
48 degrees 39 overnight we'll be colder
than that tomorrow morning 65 is our
normal so almost 20 degrees below
average the record on this date 79
degrees currently outside 43 for
centenni hills along with sky canyon 47
up in aliante camino al norte north las
vegas 47 whitney ranch 49 with 44
henderson double fours for you 43
mountains edge along with roads ranch
and 41 right now for southern highlands
setting us up for a chilly night tonight
and a cold morning start 43 in prep 39
boulder city and 52 right now for you
joining us from laughlin so let's go to
the desert radar right now that low
continues to move its way towards the
east and you can see the clearing behind
this which we're going to see the next
few hours however we just showed you the
dew point the measure of the how much
moisture is at the surface and since
it's only 19 degrees a lot of this like
we showed you earlier is not touching
the ground but up here in northeast
clark yeah we're still getting some
showers to pass through moapa there up
and also northeast clark and mesquite
and a few lingering showers right around
indian springs so futurecast really
doesn't give us a good chance for any
more showers for
the next few hours as we dry out and
clear out tonight and overnight so
here's the other big story that i
promised you we're going to show you
those numbers throughout your
neighborhoods temperatures will be
dropping at or just below freezing 30 in
summerlin 31 mountains remember 32 is
the freezing mark 32 downtown green
valley 33 32 for nellis regional lows
outside the valley 19 only for you and
trump boulder city at 31 only three
degrees up at league canyon overnight
wow
overnight tonight 33 degrees your
morning start cold and breezy skies will
be clearing for tomorrow 52 degrees
chilly and clear some light winds light
breezes for tomorrow but still remaining
way below normal for this time of the
year eight day forecast shows look at
this temperatures in those 50s a little
chilly for our morning start cold for
some that's going to last for this week
and then next week that is not an error
we're getting close to 80 degrees
next week some neighborhoods will reach
that as early as wednesday
that's a real reversal of fortunately
big time right
seriously like a stock taking off how to
go in your jacket or shorts
it depends what we can do
i'm speaking of hockey
we got to talk about this because
nicknames are so prevalent in the game
of hockey like yes you had like marshy
and carly he would be he would be called
what lofty
i don't know what that'd be called
i don't know if they do two syllables
like
that how about this robin leonard panda
that's kind of unusual yeah